mr. president thanks so much for being
with us tonight you Lou
today Mike Pompeo gave a very forceful
press conference on the fallout from the
Iranian jetliner going down his concern
is that people aren't understanding the
imminent nature of the threat of
soleimani and he was pressed on that
today he said there were large scale
attacks planned on US facilities but he
didn't go more specific don't the
American people have a right to know
what specifically was targeted without
revealing methods and sources well I
don't think so but we will tell you that
probably it was going to be the embassy
in Baghdad he saw that happening you saw
with all of the men very few women
circling it and circling it very
strongly and very vicious ly knocking
out windows and trying to get in and
they were close to getting in and I
called out the military they said we'll
have it there tomorrow said nope you'll
have it there today we're not gonna have
another Benghazi on our hands and we did
a really amazing job but get no credit
for it but we never get credit for
anything and that's okay in the meantime
we have the greatest economy we've ever
had a lot of other things but I think
you would have had another Benghazi had
we not acted quickly that could have
been stopped and this was stopped and we
had our patchi's going there they
elected the great helicopters and they
were dropping flares all over the place
and a lot of things were happening they
had action real fast and everybody
disappeared they have a large-scale
attacks plan for other embassies and if
those were planned why can't we reveal
that to the American people wouldn't
that help me your case I can reveal that
I believe it would have been for
embassies and I think that probably
Baghdad already started they were really
amazed that we came in with that kind of
a force we came in with very powerful
force and drove them out you know that
ended almost immediately but Baghdad
certainly would have been the lead but I
think it would have been for embassy
could have been military bases could
have been a lot of other things too but
it was eminent and then all of a sudden
he was gone why is Nancy Pelosi
describing her briefing
dismissive and disdainful my Cleese that
it was insulting the Intel briefing what
what wasn't said to mollify the concerns
of some of your strongest supporters
like Michael it yeah he is a great
supporter is a friend and when he called
me just a little while ago and he said
you know I just wanted to get some more
information and he was look I've also
had calls from some of the Senators some
of the congressmen said it was the
single best briefing one person said
they've been there for ten years it's
the single best briefing they've ever
had once said twenty years the single
best military briefing they've ever had
I understand what Mike had Mike wanted
certain things said and we just couldn't
say and we could probably say maybe
individually to him and he's certainly a
trustworthy person are you worried that
the Democrats can't be trusted who
classified information because that's
kind of what it sounded like when pence
gave that interview and talked about
sources and methods the other day I am
worried about it certainly I am worried
about it can you imagine
here we are split-second timing executed
like nobody's seen in many many years on
Salamone
can you imagine they want us to call up
and speak to crooked corrupt politician
Adam Schiff Oh Adam we have somebody
that we've been trying to get for a long
time we have a shot at him right now
could we meet so that we can get your
approval Adam Schiff and it's a well
let's do it in a couple of days oh okay
let's meet in a cup it doesn't work that
way number one number two they leaked
anything we give will be leaked
immediately you'll see breaking news
we're about to attack in twenty five
minutes or do something and by the way
I'm not somebody that wants to attack I
probably could have attacked five times
ten times having to do with Iran I've
been very guarded because I don't want
to do that but we may have to do
something we have to be in a position
where we can do it even from the
negotiating standpoint but hopefully it
won't be necessary we have tremendous
sanctions they're doing very poorly they
have riots all over their country and
they could straighten it out easy but
it's up to them
speaking of Elon Omar I think said today
that this
is akin to economic warfare against Iran
even though she supports sanctions
against Israel yeah she hates Israel
she hates Jewish people you just have to
take a look at her rhetoric it's
incredible what's happened to the
Democrats in Congress they used to be
supportive of Israel today they're
supportive of her and Talib that's
another real winner Talib and AOC who
knows nothing AOC knows nothing poor
student poor everything and then she
comes and she talks about the green New
Deal and all these poor fools say oh
isn't it wonderful isn't it wonderful
but you know as I said last night in
Ohio I don't like talking about the
green New Deal it's too early I want to
save it for about two weeks before
because they may change their mind
Bernie Sanders was out you're not
surprised to hear this discussing Iran
what happened and he basically said this
just as we were led into Vietnam in Iraq
by lies the Trump administration is
misleading us on Iran they have
justified the assassination of Kasim
soleimani by claiming that he was
planning imminent attacks and yet they
produced no evidence that would justify
this claim not even in a class apart
setting I don't see it happening we are
there for a very very strong reason they
cannot have nuclear weapons the Iran
nuclear deal signed by President Obama
gave 150 billion and that's when the
real terrorists started they took that
money and they used it all over the
place you look at Yemen you look at all
of the things that were happening
including Syria they were using police
they gave 1.8 billion in cash 1.7 1.8
million in cash green cash beautiful
green cash you almost say whether they
how do they have the power to do this
plane loads of cash and instead of Iran
saying thank you very much that's really
nice let's go and get along let's do
well let's do deals together let's build
buildings in a run they said death to
America and they said it when they were
signing when Kerry signed and by the way
Kerry violated the Logan
this man totally violated the Logan act
with his conversations okay
but when Carrie was out there and making
the deal
and they have people screaming death to
America death to America see who signs a
deal while they're screaming death to
America there's this ug stabilize the
Middle East after campaigning as a man
of restraint non-interventionism
Elizabeth Warren is saying this Carrie
saying that's all the old Obama folks
are out there Susan Rice they're all
kind of waiting in the wings like see
he's and he's the guy that we told you
he was if you look at the Middle East
right now it's much tamer than it was
when I got in when I got in it was just
all over the place number one we got rid
of the caliphate the Isis Caliphate we
have tens of thousands of Isis prisoners
we've killed most of their fighters
we've gotten rid of Isis now they come
back and we take care of it
other people should take care of it
other countries should take care of it
Europe should take them back as NATO
going to actually step up I know they
committed to doing more in the Middle
East but what specifically is NATO gonna
contribute that's going to take some of
the burden off the American taxpayer so
when I came in as you know native what
NATO was virtually a dead organization
it had no money nobody was paying except
us practically nobody was paying if you
look at a chart of money and funds
received it looked like a roller coaster
down now and Secretary Stoltenberg I
think he's terrific in my first year I
raised a hundred and thirty billion
dollars from them not from us and now he
just announced five hundred and thirty
billion dollars all because of me he's
my biggest salesman my greatest sales
but secretary Stoltenberg but I said to
him look you're there for Russia and
Europe okay
by the way NATO's much more for Europe
than it is for us and yet we parsley
protecting them from now the all the
money we're setting they know what are
we protecting them from well they build
an office building for three billion
dollars they do lots of things that they
shouldn't be doing before I got here
but I raised a lot of money we can use
NATO in other locations we can use NATO
as an example in the Middle East and
that's what we should do and I think
frankly it's more palatable to countries
in the Middle East if an international
force comes in rather than just the
United States and from our standpoint
let's some
else pay for it why are we always paying
we pay for everything one thing I moved
my troops out of the border between
Turkey and Syria that turned out to be
such a successful move Laura look what
happened now they protect the wrong
they've been fighting over that border
for a thousand years why should we do it
and then they say he left troops in
Syria you know what I did I left troops
to take the oil I took the oil the only
troops I have are taking the oil they're
protecting the oil
I took mine we're taking or not taking
no maybe we will maybe we won't we never
sell I don't know maybe we should take
it but we have the oil right now the
United States has the oil so they say he
left troops in Syria no I got rid of all
of them other than we're protecting the
you oh we have the oil the Wall Street
Journal is reporting today that after
this strike mr. Trump told associates he
was under pressure to deal with general
Solomonic take him out from GOP senators
he views as important supporters in the
coming impeachment trial in the Senate
associates said sounds like you got a
leaker here in the White House or
someone's what is it they just made it
up it's fake news bleeker's they just
make it up they're all very dishonest
most of them are really designed eighty
percent are dishonest and I mean really
dishonest they made that story up so no
sharing about you notice the way they
don't need no not at all by the way
absolutely not at all
we have tremendous support look in the
house we were over 196 to nothing and we
got three Democrats so therefore it was
bipartisan I guess you could say we get
none nothing they had nothing we didn't
lose one Republican vote as you know
that's very unusual in the Senate I
think I have the same if not more
support I don't have to do that I would
never compromise what we're doing with
Iran and potential war and all of the
things that what we're doing sorta doing
Bush 2.0 here this is not Bush 2.0 this
is not WM you know what I wanted in the
Middle East I don't want people having
nuclear weapons because they'll use them
I don't want people having nuclear
weapons that's my biggest thing well you
guys got out of the Iran deal
that's what's cause you know I was the
orondia I did a great thing getting out
of the run deal they gave him a hundred
and fifty billion they gave her the one
point apron and forget that you couldn't
do inspections of the most important
locations and you know another big thing
they have the right to do ballistic
missiles we couldn't go into areas and
look we'd have to give massive notices
so if they were doing something they
could clean them up it was ridiculous
but most importantly it expires this is
a short-term agreement and now once it
expired they have an absolute clear
unstop path that nuclear weapons
unstopped in a very short period of time
the deal that President Obama made with
John Kerry who may be the worst
negotiator I've ever seen that deal
expires and you know what once it
expires you can't do what I did I mean
because they have a deal that says once
it expires they can do and do what they
want to do you cannot let Iran have a
nuclear weapon that's what I'm doing
p-put a judge and other Democrats I
predicted this when I talked to Mike
Pompeo yesterday are actually blaming
your moves against Iran for the downing
of that commercial jetliner in Iran in
Tehran the night of the strikes by
around 2:00 our Iraqi facilities your
reaction to that charge well a couple of
people started that and they got hit
real fast by a lot of different people
not me I think it's just lowlife look
he's not going anywhere he was a lousy
mayor of a place that is not doing well
and Indiana's doing unbelievably well
Indiana the state had the best year
they've ever had thank you very much but
that city was badly run you look at
what's going on he's going and she's
another beauty I mean take a look at her
past
check out her past place the Iraqi Prime
Minister has notified Mike Pompeo about
potential plans drawing up plans for a
u.s. troop withdrawal from Iraq period
you ran on pulling out of the Middle
East I don't why not use this
opportunity to say okay we're done I'm
okay with it by the way
remove it and Tracy everything that's
what they say
luckily they don't say that privately
because if we leave that means then I
can realize I live I'm not so bad with
it we know when I heard that I said mmm
you know I have it down to 5,000 troops
we had many many troops there in Iraq
and we're there only in a training we
trained them but if they'd want us to
leave but they speak different publicly
than they do private always having more
trips to the region as we say we're
sending more to Saudi Arabia and Saudi
Arabia is paying us for it you know
we're doing something that nobody's ever
done I said to Saudi Arabia very good
relationship with Saudi Arabia said
listen you're a very rich country you
want more troops I'm gonna send them to
you but you've got to pay us they're
paying us
they've already deposited 1 billion
dollars in the bank we are going to help
them but these rich countries have to
pay for it South Korea gave us five
hundred million dollars they never gave
us an they gave us five hundred million
dollars I said you got to help us along
we have thirty two thousand soldiers in
South Korea protecting you from North
Korea you've got to pay and they gave us
five hundred million dollars I mean you
saw that breaking news because nobody
wants to report that stuff I'm not sure
anybody knows it I might be sort of
saying it you have some I mean it's good
stuff but they're wealthy country they
build all your television sets they took
that away from us they build the ships
they build a lot of things I said look
we're protecting you you got to pay they
paid us five hundred million they're
gonna pay us a lot more do you think
that Iraq should repay the American
taxpayer for these bases you know we've
done there heard that from me I said we
built one of the world's most expensive
airport facilities anywhere in the world
I mean I wish we had it in New York I
wish we had it in Washington we build
runways that are 15,000 feet long at
LaGuardia they're 7,000 feet long in
fact I think that 20,000 feet long over
there and
deep thick concrete and steel nobody
ever build runways like this okay I'm
you know is way over built but that's
okay but we have billions of dollars
into that I said if we leave you gotta
pay us if we leave you have to pay us
for embassies you have to pay us for the
money we put in how you're gonna collect
well we have a lot of their money right
now we have a lot of their money we have
thirty five billion dollars of their
money right now sitting in an account
and I think they'll agree to pay
I think they'll agree to pay otherwise
we'll stay there